le président mais aussi monsieur le
professeur c'est un titre auquel vous
tenez beaucoup
quel honneur pour la france et pour vous
même vous voici prix nobel de la paix
quels sont les français qui vous avaient
précédé dans cette cohorte éminente et
bien je suis très fier de l'honneur qui
m'est fait tu fais à mon pays et qui me
met dans la belle suite où il ya eu les
hambourgeois harris et de brillants les
11 jours et plus récemment albert
schweitzer qui est décédé et chacun pour
une action spéciale
je crois que personnellement c'est pour
le combat des droits de l'homme qu'après
la deuxième guerre
j'ai mené depuis 25 ans alors monsieur
le président comment avez-vous appris
cette grande nouvelle que j'ai appris en
rentrant chez moi pour voir ma femme
souffrant par les photographes et les
journalistes qui étaient prêts à me
fusiller de voir l'entraînement un
appartement vous fusille et
pacifiquement bâtiment mais je suppose
que cette distinction coïncide avec un
certain anniversaire une cervelle
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme c'est la vérité quand on vous
voit on est obligé de penser à se gérer
je suis un des artisans de cette
déclaration
je dirais même un des artisans
principaux mais je crois que mon action
plus directes pour la paix se marque
entre les deux guerres
quand j'étais président des mutilés et
anciens combattants de l'union fédérale
française
nous avons formé un grand groupement
européen a appelé la fia mac qui a
essayé de soutenir les efforts des
hommes d'état pour prévenir la guerre
c'est un titre que j'ai été délégué à la
société des nations
aux côtés de brillants des rios et de
paul boncour et ensuite aux nations
unies
en somme il ya continuité entre votre
action au lendemain de la première
l'ère reagan et votre action mais il y
as juges de la deuxième
alors eh bien je n'ai pas à cacher que
je ne trouvais pas eu égard à mes idées
supporter l'idée d'une france écrasé et
de la justice bafouée et c'est pourquoi
dès l'appel du général de gaulle suis
allé à londres je les aider à faire son
premier accord avec churchill et au fur
et à mesure que les forces de la france
combattante se sont développées j'ai été
chargé de beaucoup de choses
les lois les rapports internationaux et
les structures mais aussi nous pensions
déjà à l'organisation la paix et à ce
titre jamais dit que la france voulait
que les droits de l'homme soit inscrite
dans la future organisation la paix vous
pensiez de votre action à londres mais
vous n'oubliez pas que vous avez été
secrétaire permanent du comité de
défense aux voiliers beaucoup d'autres
choses mais en réalité les titres
n'étaient rien c'était la volonté de
vaincre de libérer notre pays est de
substituer à l'horrible barbarie
hitlérienne un régime de droit et de
justice
et c'est pourquoi depuis la fin de la
deuxième guerre je suis vous est
totalement à cette oeuvre la map
[Musique]